when I finished it and had been on the  film festival circuit with it for a year  when the uh when Miramax bought it Hari  tried to talk me into cutting the  torture scene out oh the with Mr blonde  and the guy in the chair cut off yeah uh  he tried to talk me uh out of that and  his reasoning was look Quentin this is a  movie that anybody can watch but with  that torture scene you're gonna alienate  women so you literally you're putting  your own movie in a little box and but  without that scene anybody can go and  see this movie and everybody will enjoy  it and that's kind of actually where I  became me because Harvey was used to  winning these type of arguments he had a  bunch of yes men going yeah yeah yeah  and Harvey realized he wasn't going to  get his way and he's used to getting his  way I I stood fast and there was like a  beat of like  too  four five okay we're gonna leave the  scene in and I want you to remember that  it was Miramax who left it alone